joie d'avoir savoir comment ce groupe et
enée quelle est leur formation d'où
vient-il quel était leur itinéraire à
chacun le sait peut-être à bjork je peux
cette question
abbas forme et
filles étaient des jeux sur deux solos
dans les groupes rock je chantais dans
un groupe rock quant à moi
nous avons commencé
à jouer ensemble parce que nous pensions
pouvoir faire quelque chose nous en
avions rêvé depuis très longtemps
et en 71 après avoir travaillé avec
différents groupes nous avons commencé
en tant qu'abonné
depuis leur vision vous avez gagné
rempli de rue visant les coins clou en
1974 you want
for j'aimerais savoir si vous considérez
que cette récompense a joué un rôle
important dans votre carrière
internationale
ou est-ce que le démarrage s'est fait
après you consider that is
rôle important for you in ternational
carrière or
je crois que
même s'il n'a pas gagné à brighton la
carrière se serait poursuivie
aussi vite que c'est passé mais ce
serait passer tout de même alors vous
êtes des vedettes m'attend dans le monde
entier témoin ce film qui sort mercredi
d'une heure et demie je voudrais de
demander à beni comment ce film s'est
fait de quel était le concours de
circonstances qui a fait ce film est est
ce que ça changera peut-être pour la
suite candide de films comme barreau de
beni six films
je crois qu'il soit assez longues a
raconté
moi j'essaie de l'abréger un peu
lorsqu il se devait en australie nous
savions ce qui aurait beaucoup de monde
là bas
nous voulions faire un film pour nous
avait un film d'amateur pour nous a
regardé le soir que nous aurions vieux
et si c'était bon c'est vraiment bon on
pourrait en rire disons un film de
télévision
notre directeur en a fait qui a fait
plutôt promotion
et en particulier toute l'île est
extrait du film que vous venez pas
considérer qu'il va écrire peut-être un
scénario ferrat un fil alors métrage
enfin le résultat est assez
extraordinaire c'est vraiment un film
d'une heure et demie très impressionnant
avec un son superbe je vais demander à
frida votre époux seal ce film va
peut-être changer quelques choses
risquent de changer quelque chose dans
la suite de votre carrière fluide un des
six fils sean durfy och-ziff
chaillot fioutch à mon avenir
vraiment je ne sais pas
peut-être que ça changera mais non en
raison du succès
mais peut-être que je vieillis
et donc des choses change forcément mais
vous ne voulez pas devenir actrice avec
le physique tout à fait extraordinaire
que vous avez d'une autre one week end
actrice
j'ai rien contre je n'ai rien contre
pourquoi pourquoi pas à tes des
producteurs qui regarde je voudrais vous
avez été sensible sans doute quand vous
avez écouté pour la première fois le les
disques du groupe abba par la qualité
technique l'enregistrement et du son et
dans le film qui leur est consacrée qui
sort dans quelques jours vous verrez que
c'est un centre est enregistrée lors de
leur tournée en australie le son est
absolument extraordinaire on a rarement
vu ça j'aimerais savoir
comment comment ils travaillent ensemble
car je sais que benny et björn son
responsable également de complètement de
la technique quand ils enregistrent
leurs disques wayne wallison yoriko swan
adma est de qualité audio sans la
qualité de votre
[Musique]
offre
je voudrais savoir si c'est une façon
nouvelle d'envisager ce métier de
surveiller à la fois la technique
l'enregistrement et cetera et cetera de
you consider that its own you and your
business to be bop composent un génie
la save the sand
singer of course
non je ne crois pas que ce soit quelque
chose de nouveau mais je crois que c'est
une bonne technique
parce que vous pouvez tellement
contrôler tout du début jusqu'à la fin
ce qui est excellent
mais maintenant beaucoup de groupes
travaillent que comme cela les bee gees
par exemple heroes freedom à qui ils
font tous reprise de son tout
militaire béni oui nos propres récoltes
je crois que la seule responsabilité
que nous veillions ses vis à vis de nous
mêmes en fait de faire une musique aussi
bonne que cela est possible rien d'autre
je ne pense pas que nous ayons d'autres
responsabilités que vis-à-vis de
nous-mêmes a demandé mme agnetha qu'elle
me réponde franchement et sa petite
camarade frida également tu es ce que
vous avez déjà eu envie de chanter seul
peut-être pas d'abandonner le groupe
mais d'essayer de vous lancer tout seul
tell me that should
have you ever been taken to make ricort
delaune
eh bien on est toujours tenté
de faire quelque chose de nouveau
quelque chose de différent et l'année
dernière frida et moi même ensemble nous
avons fait un album solo
mais nous ne pensons pas que c'est
nécessaire de le faire tant que groupe
est ensemble
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pour
l'avenir ayew fly by the future rocade
puisque vous êtes très jeune en veillant
à you never qui veut répondre
béni
non j'ai pas peur personne n'a peur d'un
groupe
tellement longtemps que le travaillant
dans ce domaine 10 12 ans déjà pour les
quatre que je crois que nous
continuerons à travailler dans le show
business et la musique toujours
tout ce qui se passe actuellement avec
succès dans le monde entier ce n'est pas
la chose la plus importante ce qui est
plus important c'est d'être engagée de
travailler avec quelque chose qui vous
plaît vraiment c'est mon sentiment
personnel apparemment vous n'avez aucune
angoisse aux professionnels à votre
place j'aurais tourné un petit peu peur
j'aurais peur de
voir mes deux femmes s'envoler car vu le
succès qu'elles ont dans le monde entier
sera un petit peu inquiet je crois
qu'elle a d'ailleurs compris ce que je
viens de dire une note fred someone my
style
je crois que ça leur appartient de
décider mais ça arrange aussi parce que
vu la réaction des techniciens de la
télévision quand elles sont arrivées
j'aurais été à votre place un petit pain
qui joue merci beaucoup cinq verges nous
avons été très fier et très honoré de
votre visite au havre pro tout elle
commis en dix-sept because we are very
busy car je sais que vous êtes très très
occupé et vous avez un emploi du temps
très chargé ce pour plusieurs - parrot
tout tous les signaux fin seconde visite
love is it makes it j'espère vous
recevoir plus longuement encore l'année
prochaine ok voilà vous pouvez
maintenant profiter de la bonne bouffe
française et du vin français s'était
remis ses propres
[Musique]